hello everyone after that wild game
against between Scottish and Komodo it's
time to go back to some human and human
action and we are back at the bent row
blitz Club on a cup on just 24 in a game
between Nagas cross and versus salmon
sugar of his old nemesis as it is to him
that Carlson lost one of his worse
suffered one of his first defeats of his
chest career if you haven't seen that
game I will put a link to it in the
description below it will be the first
thing you see if you want to check that
out but it's the semi-finals and we are
going to see who proceeds to the finals
so Magnus with the white pieces opens
with E 4 and they've played nine games
in this match and it was really hard to
decide which game to show but I think
you'll understand why I chose this one
so e 5 we have a knight to f3 Knight to
c6 and Bishop to c4 Magnus goes for them
Italian opening with the ship to c5 and
now of course you could play a lot of
things here one of the ideas is also you
could go for B for the Evans gambit and
it is exactly what Magnus played in this
game so as a move for the Evans gambit
is on the board and of course you get
over accepts the challenge Bishop
captures done before we have c3 and now
as we mentioned in the previous video
where it was played the most usual
retreats are a 5 and B 7 B 6 somewhat
rare as c c5 is is a bad idea and here
we have Bishop to e7 a long time ago I
think I've read this is the Hungarian
way of defending against the Evans
gambit but I could be wrong but ok
before now grabbing the center as you
should do when you go for the Evans
gambit and now Knight a5 the idea
combined with Bishop to e7 now
threatening to remove the bishop from c4
but also you white could just go for
captures captures and captures and allow
black thus freeing d5 move which is
definitely or okay for black so Magnus
instead decides to keep the tension
Bishop to e2 and now there are actually
games in the database where d6 or ecad
person d4 was played but here we have d5
it's a it's a really crazy idea it's not
a new move but you can see that already
the position is just exploding
Magnus goes for Queen to a4 would check
will see
it's blocking and now just pawn captures
on e5 and now there is one game where D
captures and e4 was played but here we
have b5 and it is as of move 9 do we
have a completely new game so Magnus
retreats Queen to c2 maybe it was better
to capture the pawn right away maybe
then b5 as now the queen is already
guarding the e4 pawn and also Black has
some issues on how to develop the knight
and castle the safety as the bishop
prevents it from being developed the 7
point guards f6 so you might go Knight
to h6 but probably best is to capture go
Bishop to c5 and then develop the knight
via the e7 square but here is you get of
decides to go for Knight h6 checking if
Magnus is interested in giving up the
bishop pair which he does so he bust
open the King's position here on the
Kings side we have G captures on h6 and
now just Knight B to d2 asking black
what do you want to do do you want to
keep her King in the center do you want
to castle do you want to maybe develop
some pieces on the Queen set and Castle
queenside and first Bishop to e6
we have castles by Magnus not worried
about ideas like rook to g8 as he he
feels confident that he will be able to
defend this but also the black King is
still in the center of the board so it's
not black who will be attacking in this
game but okay here you get of just
castles as well and now Knight the d4
just improving the position of the night
also Knight to f5 might be an idea in
the future so Queen to c7 developing
putting more defense on the c6 pawn and
also preparing to capture on e5 so f4
just defending and now D captures on e4
which allows Magnus to improve the
position of his knight Knight captures
here on e4 and here it's it's a very
tough position to play as black your
Kings position is a bit ruined you do
have the bishop pair although you have
to make them fully operational until
then they're not really all that
impressive and here you should go for
some like King h8 bring the rook to g8
maybe double up on the G file and play
that game but here sugar of plate c5
instead attacks the night and it's it's
a bit of a weird move as it
the b5 born so here Carson accepts it
not with that night he's not a Wilson
the hustler Knight captures on b5
attacking the Queen and now Queen to c6
attacking both of the Knights even
though the Knights are defended but puts
pressure and now we have Knight to d6
just an excellent square for the knight
and now f5 trying to kick away this
night and then you're gonna win back
your pawn for example captures captures
and the Queen will capture on d6 however
Magnus finds it a very interesting night
the g3 move here and the problem is a
blacks Queen and rook are on this
diagonal and the bishop to f3 will cause
a lot of problems so here black goes for
Bishop captures and d6 but now and in
between move Bishop to f3 and I
suspicion to saying that okay now if you
move I'm just gonna capture and then
recapture on d6 or if you block which is
what happened in the game Bishop
captures on d5 Queen captures in the now
rook a to d1 again putting more pressure
here so you don't have to whoops
so you don't have to give up your pawn
back we have Queen back to f7 and only
now rook captures and e6 keeping the e5
pawn intact we have nice to see for now
puts pressure on Carlson's rook and also
with some ideas of nice to e3 to get
this fork in there
so rook the f6 attacking the Queen Queen
to d7 and then now comes Queen to d2 not
allowing Knights to e3 to go for the
fork
look at verse on f6 pawn captures now
with the double def pawn but also it's
it's a very strong power passed pawn we
have Knight to d6 hoping to get rook to
e8 and followed by Knight to e4 to get
this out was for the night but here of
course calls and prevents it we have
rook to d1 and now rook to d8 adding
adding more defenders there but now
across and just played the Queen to e7
and it was in this position that silence
you get or resign the game and yet
another victory in the Evans gambit for
for world champion Magnus Carlsen so
here you're you resigned because well if
you decline the trade alas the Queen C
since then it's Queen g7 mate if you
accept the Queen trade captures captures
you're just lost because well you either
the queens were and then you lose the
night or you try and guard both let's
say the night covers the the queening
square but now just you bring a queen
enter game characters and you are down a
whole rook and other than that not
really much to do you you could just
ignore the Queen move and play something
it totally did let's say c4 but then
it's just f7 check and you get another
queen in terror game check and it's just
made it this way so really nothing to do
after Queen t7 here still Grove resigned
and and like I said an excellent victory
for Magnus crossing in the Evan's Evan's
gambit and yeah that's one only one of
the games the match ended in nine to
zero in crossings favor so it was really
just just a futuristic performance if
you will cause and precedes that the
final of the banter blitz Cup and here
wait so will it be in arianna or earlier
as a future who will join him in the
finals so that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed like I said to check out across
and versus you get over the game I've
mentioned in the beginning of the video
first thing you see in the description
below I would like to thank Don Crawford
a markup annenberg cara mclean burke
Palvin a vine burg and andrea rogers for
her contribution to my channel thank you
a lot - really appreciate it as usual
you can check to my previous video serum
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the coverage of the Morphy
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day